es uno de los rostros más prominentes de
la disidencia cubana desde las masivas
protestas de julio en la isla de goa
madrid según él porque su vida y la de
su familia corrían peligro en cuba-
juniors el principal impulsor de unas
fallidas protestas contra el gobierno
convocadas para el 15 de noviembre y que
el ejecutivo aplacó con un gran
despliegue de las fuerzas de seguridad
aterrizó en su el espanyol como turista
y afirma que su intención no es pedir
asilo porque planea volver a su país que
no se trata de un gobierno se trata de
una dictadura y si alguien tiene
problemas con esa palabra pues bueno
también está la palabra tiranía pero en
un lugar donde las personas son tratadas
como gusanos porque así nos llaman donde
las personas son aplastadas amenazadas
no se puede hablar de que haya ningún
tipo de democracia dejamos de usar
adjetivos la democracia existe o no
dramaturgo de 39 años es el líder del
grupo opositor archipiélago y ha cobrado
relevancia desde que en julio miles de
personas marcharon en rechazo al
gobierno denunciando la escasez de
bienes de primera necesidad y la falta
de libertades civiles entre otras
demandas
fue la movilización más grande desde la
red cubana para el gobierno júnior
trabaja en secreto para washington no
hay madera de mártires en los que
organizan este tipo de falsas y
operaciones fallidas
bajo instrucción y financiamiento del
gobierno de los eeuu señor dice que
seguirá haciendo lo que pueda por el
pueblo cubano y acepta las críticas de
aquellos seguidores que lo señalan por
haber abandonado la isla